Alright, do take your Bibles in turn with me to John chapter 15.
John chapter 15.
We've come now to the final I Am statement from Jesus in the gospel of John.
So throughout we've been seeing that Jesus says that He is the I Am.
He is the perfect revelation of God, the God who is self-existent and eternally existent.
Jesus says that is who I am.
And as the one who is the I Am, He is the source of life.
He came to give eternal life to everyone who believes in His name.
So this isn't just written so that we might know about what Jesus says about Himself,
so that we might know the living Christ, that we might have eternal life in Him.
And this morning we're going to see that Jesus is not only the source of life, but also the
source of fruitfulness.
He is our life and He's the source of our growth and the one who is going to bring about
the fruit that we have been made to bear.
So let's read John chapter 15.
We're going to read verses 1 down to verse 11.
It says, I am the true vine and my father is the vine dresser.
Every branch in me that does not bear fruit, he takes away.
And every branch that does bear fruit, he prunes that it may bear more fruit.
Already you are clean because of the word that I have spoken to you.
Abide in me and I in you.
As the branch cannot bear fruit by itself unless it abides in the vine, neither can
you unless you abide in me.
I am the vine.
You are the branches.
Whoever abides in me and I in him, he it is that bears much fruit.
For apart from me, you can do nothing.
If anyone does not abide in me, he is thrown away like a branch and withers and the branches
are gathered, thrown into the fire and burned.
If you abide in me and my words abide in you, ask whatever you wish and it will
be done for you.
By this my father is glorified that you bear much fruit and so prove to be my
disciples.
As the father has loved me, so have I loved you.
Abide in my love.
If you keep my commandments, you will abide in my love just as I have kept my
father's commandments and abide in his love.
These things I have spoken to you that my joy may be in you and that your joy
may be full.
This is the word of the Lord.
Let's pray.
Lord, we do thank you for your word and Lord, I pray that you would speak to us
now as we look at it together.
Lord, I pray that we would know your abiding presence with us nor we
acknowledge that apart from you we can do nothing.
So Lord, I pray that you would enable me to proclaim your word now and that
you would open all of our eyes that we may see more of Jesus.
In his name we pray.
Amen.
All right, well, Jesus and his disciples were told have just walked outside and
he's going to continue to teach his disciples until they reach a garden.
And in that garden, Jesus is going to be betrayed, but it's not surprising that
now that they're outside and making their way to a garden that Jesus uses,
a botanical language, if you will, to teach his disciples.
He speaks of himself as a vine, and he speaks of his father as a vine dresser
or as a gardener, and he speaks of us as the branches.
So the disciples are the branches.
We're going to take each one of those one at a time, and we're going to
see that what Jesus says is far deeper than just taking some kind of
illustration from outdoors.
There's a long history here of God speaking about the vine.
So let's look at the vine, the gardener, and the branches together.
So first of all, Jesus says in verse one, I am the true vine.
Then in verse five, he repeats it again, although slightly differently.
And he says, I am the vine and you are the branches.
So Jesus is claiming to be the vine here or the true vine.
This is his final I am statement out of the seven that are connected to
a picture in the Gospel of John.
Well, in the Old Testament, there are a number of places where the people
of Israel specifically are referred to as a vine.
So you look at Isaiah chapter five and Jeremiah chapter two among other places.
You see Israel is spoken of as a vine.
But if you look at the front of your worship guides, I thought we would
start off by reading that Psalm together today because there in Psalm 80,
Israel is referred to as a vine.
So you look in verse eight, for example, it says you brought a vine out of Egypt.
So looking back to their time of slavery there, you brought a vine out of Egypt.
You drove out the nations.
This is in the Promised Land and you planted it.
The people of Israel are like a vine.
They've been planted by God.
When you look across the Old Testament, including Psalm 80 and see
what it's teaching about the vine, actually he's speaking about God's judgment
because they had been planted by God and he wanted them to bear the fruit of justice
and righteousness, but they failed.
And as a result, the vine is then cut down.
And so when you look at this vine that's been cut down, the situation
seems pretty, pretty hopeless.
When we moved to Gardendale back in September, we looked at the different plants
that were in our yard and the one that we were not anticipating was this
these huge banana plants.
And I've never seen a banana plant or a banana tree before that I knew of
or never thought of what it would take to care for one of them.
But as it started approaching winter, the leaves started to die.
And you're talking these like 12 foot tall, really, really tall plants.
And so we started hacking off a few of the leaves.
But then I heard somewhere that you're actually supposed to hack the entire
thing down before the cold sets in.
And so one day I just went to town and started hacking these things to pieces
right down to these stubs on the ground.
And before long, it was clear they are very dead.
And so as I was looking at them, I thought, OK, I've done it now.
Like, we're never going to see these things again.
Weeks went by and we thought, yeah, we're never going to see these things again.
So what are we going to do in the place where these used to be?
But then a couple of weeks ago, sure enough, these shoots started to spring up
beside the old stubs, you know, these banana plants starting to come up again.
So we are hopeful as we're looking on.
All right. Well, as we as we see Psalm 80 there in the worship guide
or in your in your Bible, you see there's this prayer that God would
look on this vine in this hopeless situation.
And it's a prayer that life would be restored there.
But there we see that the hope for the vine is going to be found
in a single shoot because it doesn't just speak about the vine.
It also speaks about the coming of the son of man.
This coming son of man is spoken of as the as the source of life.
He is the source of hope for the people of Israel.
And another way of saying that would be to say that this one
who was going to come is going to be the the true vine.
So this is what Jesus is claiming for himself here in John 15.
He says, I am the true vine.
Another way of saying this would be to say this, Jesus is the true Israel.
So throughout throughout the gospel of John, we've seen all these different
illusions in the Old Testament that were pointing to the coming of Jesus
from from the bread in the wilderness and the the tabernacle
and all these different things.
All these were pointing to the coming of Jesus and were fulfilled in him.
And then here we see that Jesus is the the true Israel that Israel itself,
the people of God themselves pointed to the coming of Jesus.
So Israel's calling to be this vine that would that would grow and bear fruit
is fulfilled by Jesus because it is in him that is life.
He is the one who fills the world with true righteousness and justice.
But interestingly, he soon would be cut down himself.
But not for any sin of his own.
So on the cross, he is cut down as it were.
He suffers and he dies for our sins.
Then three days later in this hopeless situation.
The life of the I am then springs up from the garden tune.
And as life continues to bear fruit to this day.
In the lives of all those who belong to him.
So we see that Jesus is the true Israel, but also in saying that to say that Jesus
is the source of life to all who are in him.
So it is in him that we find eternal life.
So eternal life isn't found in belonging to a particular country.
And is it found in belonging to a particular church?
It comes from being in Christ.
So just as a branch has a living in organic union with a vine.
So our life comes through union with Jesus.
It flows from him and we receive this through faith in Christ.
So faith is the empty hand that receives the life of Jesus.
And the life that he gives brings us into a relationship that is closer than any we
have ever known.
It brings us into a relationship with God where we dwell in him and he dwells in us.
So it's like what Paul said in Galatians chapter 2 and verse 20.
He said, I am crucified with Christ.
So there's that union with Jesus.
I'm crucified with Christ.
Nevertheless, I live, yet not I.
But Christ lives in me.
And the life that I now live in the flesh, I live by the faith of the Son of God who
loved me and gave himself for me.
So he says, the life that you're seeing is in my life.
It is the life of Christ coming through in me because I'm united to him.
So if our trust is in Christ, our life is bound up to his like a vine and a branch.
So Jesus is the true vine.
He also tells us something about the Father.
What does he say?
The Father is the gardener.
So verse one, I am the true vine.
My Father is the vine dresser.
Or gardener is another way to say the same thing.
One thing I've learned to enjoy over the years because Julia enjoys it is to
go and visit a good English garden.
We did that a number of years living in England.
There's some beautiful ones over there.
So if you ever go and visit, I would highly recommend that you have a look at
some of those.
But when we moved to Birmingham, we were glad to see that, you know, there's
the Birmingham Botanical Gardens.
And that's a great place to go.
It's a nice scenery, great place to take a walk.
But when you go and you look at all the beautiful scenery there, you're
not looking at something that was just planted at one point a long time
ago.
There's a lot of work that goes into maintaining that and kind of
curating what is going on there so that we can see and we can enjoy it.
Here in our text, we're seeing that God is the gardener and the Father with
His perfect wisdom and skill is tending to the vine and doing what is
necessary to ensure that it flourishes, that it bears much fruit.
So how does the Father, this masterful gardener, tend to the vine
and to the branches?
Well, there are a couple things that our attention is drawn to here.
One is that He removes unfruitful branches.
And the other is that He prunes fruitful branches that they might bear more
fruit.
You see that in verse 2 here.
So let's take those one at a time.
First of all, the Father removes the branches that do not bear fruit.
So we'll look at this shortly, but when He's speaking about fruit here,
He's speaking about, definitely speaking about the fruit of righteousness.
So Jesus goes on to speak about our obedience and our love and our joy.
So this is the kind of fruit that's coming through in our lives.
It's the same kind of fruit that Paul referred to in Galatians chapter 5
verses 22 and 23 as the fruit of the Spirit.
But the fruit of the Spirit, He says, is love, joy, peace, patience, kindness,
goodness, faithfulness, gentleness, and self-control.
But in what Jesus says here in the text, verse 2 and elsewhere, is clear.
There is no such thing to put it plainly.
There's no such thing as a fruitless Christian, period.
People may claim to belong to Him,
but if this kind of fruit is not evident in their life, that is not the case.
If the life of Christ is present, it will be seen in the fruit that is born in our lives.
So what about those then who claim to be followers of Christ and yet do not bear fruit?
Let's read it again, verse 2.
Every branch in me that does not bear fruit, He, that is the Father, takes away.
He takes away.
So I don't know if you've pruned, I don't know, a tree or plants in your yard.
We've got some like crepe myrtles that we're, you know, got to go and remove the kind of dead branches from
so that it might continue to grow and flourish well.
This is what it's speaking about here with the Father's work.
It takes the lifeless branches that have a kind of external attachment to Jesus or to the church,
but do not have true signs of spiritual life and they are cut off and they are removed.
Now that's not to say that they don't appear to bear fruit in certain areas.
They might be really nice people.
But what appears to be fruit isn't coming from the life of Christ in them.
It isn't being produced by His life for the glory of God.
Now we may not be able to tell whether or not that's the case.
Let's say in most instances we absolutely cannot tell, you know, who is truly in the vine and who is not.
But here we see the Father knows.
The Father knows those who truly belong to Him.
One of the ways, though, that people show themselves to be false disciples is when they walk away from Christ.
Well, they walk away from His church.
So Jesus returns to the subject of fruitless branches in verse 6.
This is where I'm getting this from.
He says this,
If anyone does not abide or remain in me,
He is thrown away like a branch and withers.
And the branches are gathered, thrown into the fire and burned.
So by this time when Jesus says this near the end of His ministry,
there are a number of people who have already ceased to follow Him.
And something has actually just happened.
Judas has just left the disciples.
So he's gone to betray Jesus.
So on the outside, Judas appeared to be a true disciple just like the others,
but that was not the case.
And this is evidenced by the fact that he does not abide or remain with Jesus.
In fact, you have in chapter 16 in verse 1 where Jesus says that he's told them these things.
He says, I have said all these things to you to keep you from falling away.
So there's a danger here of falling away.
And by when that happens, when they fall away, what is going on here?
Verse 8, it is those who bear much fruit who prove to be His disciples.
They're proving that they are not disciples of Jesus.
Now this does not stop with Judas where he leaves the disciples.
You go on to see in the life of the early church,
those who appear to be following Christ for a little while,
they appear to be true believers and then they leave.
And so John, who actually writes this gospel, writes the epistle of John,
1 John, to help churches think through this.
And he writes this about those who have left.
He says, they went out from us.
This is 1 John 2 in verse 19.
They went out from us, but they were not of us.
For if they had been of us, they would have continued or abided with us.
But they went out that it might become plain that they are not of us.
So those who leave Christ in His church aren't a kind of proof that,
you know, somebody who was once saved can now then be lost.
So what when John is speaking in 1 John 2, 9 and verse 19,
he's showing that or he's treating their walking away as a demonstration
that they never truly knew Christ, that His life was never truly dwelling within them.
They may have things that appeared like outward signs of life,
but it wasn't coming from the life of the vine.
And there are some like them or like Judas who removed themselves within their lifetime
and walk away.
But there are others who stay alongside the people of God all the way until the day that they die,
like branches who were still alongside other branches.
But in the end, the Father removes everyone who does not belong to Christ,
everyone who has not been united to Him.
Now one thought that should be really sobering to us
is how dangerously normal and respectable it is to go to church
and to identify as a Christian in Alabama.
I'm convinced that there are many people who would drop that in a heartbeat
if they then moved to another part of the world where it was dangerous
or perhaps even laughable to identify as a Christian or as a follower of Christ.
The thing is where we live in our context,
you can have false branches comfortably stay right alongside true branches
and you would never know because it's culturally acceptable to identify as a branch
to be connected with Jesus.
So here someone's faith really can't be seen in how they identify,
whether or not they identify as a Christian.
What Jesus speaks of here about fruit remains true.
What does give evidence that we are in Christ is how we live the fruit of our lives.
So we can identify as a Christian but if the fruit is not there,
it may very well be a sign that we do not truly know Him.
So you have to ask yourself the question,
am I happy to identify with Christ but am yet unwilling for Him to identify areas in my life
that need to be changed?
I want to kind of have the benefits of Christ but not any kind of change
and I just want to do things my own way.
If that is the case, please repent and come to Christ before it is too late.
If the life of Christ is truly present, you will bear fruit.
The Father will see to it.
We also see so He removes false branches but He prunes the true branches.
Why? That they might bear more fruit.
So these branches are already fruit bearing branches.
There's some fruit there but they can still bear more fruit.
So God wants to bring about verse 2, more fruit.
In verse 9 it says that He is glorified in our lives when we bear much fruit
and that is brought about by pruning.
So in other words, to just give some comfort for what we just said about
is my life bearing the fruit of Christ or not,
that isn't to say that your life is perfectly bearing all the fruits of the Spirit.
Because over here you see that there are those who truly belong to Christ
and yet they have a lot of room to grow.
And I'm one of those people.
We need to bear more fruit. The Father wants to bring about much fruit.
So we can still belong and have a lot of room to grow.
The Father does this pruning work.
It's interesting. There are two words in Greek here that are almost identical.
They're really the same word in two different forms.
But you can't see it in the English.
So one of them is in verse 2 and it speaks about how the Father prunes.
But then in verse 3, notice what it says.
It says, already you are clean because of the word I have spoken to you.
Mark that word clean. It's the same word as the word prunes in the previous verse.
When it talks about pruning, that's a verb and this is the same word in the kind of adjective form.
So why is it important for us to see that both of those things are the same thing?
Because one, he says you are already clean in verse 3.
You have already been pruned.
And in verse 2 he's saying, and there's an ongoing pruning work that is taking place in your life.
So what does that mean for us? Why is that important to see?
Because this, if you are a Christian, this is true of you right now.
If your faith is in Christ, you have already been declared righteous in Him.
His life is present.
All of the righteousness that you are called to has already been given to you in Him.
That is a fixed reality.
Interesting, you go back and John, you see that Jesus already spoke about the disciples being clean.
He said, yet not all of you, not Judas.
So that wasn't true of Him.
But if your trust is in Christ, you are already clean. You are already pruned.
And yet there is this ongoing progressive work that is happening in your life
where God is at work in you to bring out the fruit of righteousness in your life.
So that's how he can say that God is continuing to prune, that we might bear more fruit.
So we have the righteousness of Christ.
We've been declared righteous.
God is at work to bring that righteousness through in that kind of pruning work.
So this is why Paul prays that the church in Philippians 1 verse 11,
he prays that they might be filled with the fruit of righteousness that comes through Jesus Christ
to the glory and praise of God.
So like a gardener pruning a plant, God is at work in us that we might grow in the likeness of Christ.
Now, growing can be a painful process.
Pruning shears are sharp, but the gardener does not cut in order to wound
but to bring about flourishing, to bring about fruit, to help us to become who we already are, so to speak.
So what's this painful process God is bringing us through?
It can be really hard and painful to identify areas in our lives where we need to grow
and to admit that and to go through the process of change.
And on top of that, God also brings us through circumstances that are difficult,
but he does so providentially why to bring about our growth in Christ.
This is why you have the Psalmist saying in Psalm 119 in verse 71,
it is good for me that I was afflicted, that I was pruned, so to speak,
that I might learn your statutes, that I might know what you have truly said, the truthfulness of that.
So no matter what we're going through, God is skillfully at work with our good in view.
Even when we are disciplined, Hebrews chapter 12 verse 10 says,
the Heavenly Father disciplines us for our good that we may share in His holiness.
So the process of growing in holiness can be painful, but it always produces good fruit.
And it's the Father who is bringing this about.
Philippians 2.13 says, it is God who is at work in you to desire and to do that which is pleasing to Him.
So Jesus is the vine, Father is the gardener.
We are the branches.
So let's finish by looking at these branches.
So what is a branch to do?
Well up to this point, everything we've seen is about what is being done to us.
So what are we to do?
Well really that's kind of succinctly summarized in one word that's repeated many times over here.
And that's the word abide.
Branches are called to abide in the vine.
So verse 4, abide in me and I in you.
As the branch cannot bear fruit by itself unless it abides in the vine,
neither can you unless you abide in me.
I am the vine, you are the branches, whoever abides in me and I am him,
he it is that bears much fruit.
For apart from me you can do nothing.
We'll continue on to speak about abiding here.
So what does it mean then to abide in Christ?
Well it definitely means to remain in Christ.
The word actually comes up in the New Testament a lot,
but it's almost always in reference to like staying in somebody's house.
So Jesus abides for a certain amount of time.
I was thinking of when we were missionaries in West Africa
there came a point in time when our ceiling collapsed
and Julie was sitting there and all of a sudden the ceiling started kind of sliding down
or she was sitting at the table with the kids and she ran out
and the ceiling eventually just collapsed.
Well prior to then we had made some good friends
that we would go and visit for lunch occasionally
and then we all of a sudden needed a place not to visit for lunch but to abide.
And so we phoned them up and they were like absolutely come on move in
and so we lived with them for the next three weeks.
So that second scenario where you're actually moving in,
that is abiding.
That's the way the language is used in the New Testament.
But when it speaks about Christ abiding or us abiding in Him,
it's something even longer happening.
It's something that is happening eternally.
So Christ abides with us.
He makes his home with us as we saw in chapter 14.
And He doesn't just stay for a few weeks.
He stays forever.
He's promised to never leave us or forsake us.
His love is steadfast.
His love is a love as the old hymn says that will not let me go.
He holds on to us.
That's how we are secure in Him as a branch in a vine
because of His abiding, steadfast love.
But one evidence that Christ is abiding in us
is when we abide in Him.
It's the fruit of what you might call persevering faith.
So this word means remain.
Remain with me, remain with me, remain with me.
Judas has just gone.
His others have just gone.
Remain.
And yet He says to these disciples,
persevere, stay with me.
What do they do here in just a second?
When He's arrested, they all flee.
They all leave Him.
They run.
So abiding cannot mean that we never doubt
or that we never fail
or that we never leave.
But what it does mean is that if the life of Christ
is truly present, He will bring us to repentance.
He will bring us to a point where we are returning to Him
and putting our faith in Him.
Jesus makes it clear here, true disciples remain with Christ.
But not only that, there's more to just staying here.
True disciples also receive from Christ.
It is as we remain in Christ that He enables us to bear fruit.
Whoever abides in me, and I in Him, verse 5,
He it is that bears much fruit.
For apart from me, you can do nothing.
So we bear fruit through Christ.
So we receive it from Him as we abide.
And this fruit is, we've already seen what it is, this righteousness.
But when you take what Jesus says about obedience and love
and joy in the passage, we see that the fruit that He calls us to
is obedience from the heart.
So Jesus changes our hearts.
He changes our thoughts, our attitudes, and our actions.
All of that is flowing from Him in and through our lives.
So true righteousness isn't just about doing the right things,
but doing it out of a heart of love and delight in Christ.
And abiding in Jesus is recognizing where that righteousness comes from.
It's receiving it from Him because this fruit isn't something we can produce on our own.
Branches don't produce fruit.
It doesn't say you will produce much fruit.
It says you will bear much fruit.
He produces it.
We bear it.
We bear this fruit of glad obedience.
So if you were to remove a branch from a vine, it would not bear fruit.
It comes from Christ.
But this isn't a call to passivity.
We just wait around waiting for Jesus to give us this fruit of righteousness.
We're still called to forsake unrighteousness and to choose righteousness.
So He isn't saying we should just sit around waiting for it to turn up.
This call to abide is also a call to learn to live in a posture of dependence upon Him continually.
So to continually live in a posture of dependence on Jesus.
We're saying, Lord, without you I cannot do anything.
I'm humbly and eagerly looking to Christ to give me all that He has promised,
to give me all that I need to live the life that He has made me to live.
I know apart from Him I can't do anything.
So I'm to consciously and continually depend on Him.
What's that look like practically too?
To receive this from Jesus.
To rely on Him in dependence.
Well we're told a couple of things here.
Well one is to abide in Christ is to have not only Him dwelling in us, verse 7,
but to have His words abiding in us as well.
So it's to receive from His words.
So those who are consciously abiding in Christ or those who are abiding in His word,
it's His word that is like sap flowing from the vine to the branches.
It is His word in us that gives life and produces fruits.
2 Peter chapter 1 verses 3 and 4.
It says this, it says that God has granted to us very great and precious promises
so that through them we may become partakers of the divine nature,
having escaped the corruption that is in the world because of sinful desires.
So we've partaken the divine nature in the righteousness of Christ,
if you will, through the great and precious promises He's given us in His word.
In a couple of weeks we're going to begin a new series in the book of Psalms.
We'll tell you more about that when we get there, but naturally we're going to begin in Psalm 1.
I don't want to get ahead of myself with that, but there we see that this man who is blessed,
who lives a life of happiness and fruitfulness is also the man who meditates on the word of God day and night.
So there's a correspondence between fruitfulness and meditating on the word of God.
So what does it look like to rely on Jesus as to want to hear His voice?
It's coming to His word and reading it and listening to it and memorizing it and mulling it over,
not just as a discipline or as a weight that we're bearing,
but because we want to receive all that He has for us because we want to hear from Him.
And as we're hearing from Him, God then uses this to shape our thoughts, our attitudes, our actions.
It looks like listening to the word, but also looks like on the flip side, coming to God in prayer.
So we see this as well in our text.
We speak about coming to the Lord in prayer if you abide in me, verse 7.
And my words abide in you. Ask whatever you wish and it will be done for you.
So that's not saying that God is like some kind of like Jeannie in a bottle,
you know, where His wish or our wish is His command or anything like that.
But see what's going on here.
As our thoughts and our desires are being shaped by the word of Christ,
and as we're then coming to God in prayer, we'll be coming to God asking for things that are His will.
When our thoughts and desires are being shaped by the word of God,
we will ask for things that are in line with what He wants to give us.
Anyway, we will desire and ask Him to work through whatever it is we are going through
to produce the fruit of His Spirit in our lives for His glory.
But here we see this in thinking about the Lord's word and in prayer.
We see that this is what our communion or rather our union with Christ is for.
So our union with Jesus leads us into communion with God.
It's not enough to just know that like I am united to Christ and just know that as a kind of propositional truth.
Although it's important to know that.
We're being told this so that we follow where it leads.
So you don't have a closer relationship than this branch being united to this vine where we are in Christ and He is in us.
So this is an invitation to experience this living relationship with God
and to rely on Him each moment of each day that we might live for His glory
with the very help of His Spirit.
So may He draw us ever nearer that we might enjoy Him both now and forever.
Let's pray.
Lord I pray that you would teach us to abide.
Lord there is no place that we could go that we would be better than Jesus.
So I pray that you would keep our eyes fixed on Him.
Lord as we're looking to Him Lord I pray that you would assure our hearts that He has made His home with us.
Lord I pray that we would know your presence and help in our lives that our trust would be in you.
Or we thank you that you are God of steadfast love who keeps us.
So Lord I pray that knowing that you are holding on to us that we would also hold on to you as well.
That we would want to hear from your word.
That we would want to come to you in prayer.
Or that you would teach us to be dependent upon your Spirit to help us to live for your glory.
Lord teach us to depend on you.
I pray that we would know Jesus as the vine.
As our source of life and growth.
In His name we pray.
Amen.